hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live die Türkei hat gewählt und
das Rennen zwischen dem amtierenden
Präsidenten Erdogan und seinem
Herausforderer ist eng aber eben nicht
ganz so eng wie erwartet schauen wir auf
das aktuelle Zwischenergebnis nach
Auszählung fast aller Stimmen das ist
jetzt stand 9:12 Uhr
demnach stand 11:23 Uhr das ist der
aktuelle demnach kommt der absinhaber
Erdogan auf
49,4 % der Stimmen der Herausforderer
von der Cap auf knapp 45% und der
ultra-nationalistische Kandidat oan auch
5,2%. wenn kein Kandidat über die
erforderliche Marke von 50% kommt gibt
es eine Stichwahl und die soll am 28 Mai
stattfinden
soweit also der aktuelle Stand der Dinge
dieser Wahl Krimi geht also weiter
unterstellt sich die Frage bleibt
Erdogan an der Macht darüber sprechen
wir mit unserer türkei-reporterin Anna
Feist in Istanbul wir haben den Wahl
Beobachter Frank Schwabe wir haben
gleich Christian Brakel von der
Heinrich-Böll-Stiftung in Istanbul wir
schalten zu Dominik Müller Russell nach
Köln er hat da die türkische Community
begleitet und wir haben mit der
CDU-Politikerin sehr kühler gesprochen
die gerade in der Türkei ist also ihr
seht es gibt viel zu besprechen und da
freuen uns natürlich wenn ihr mitredet
schreibt uns eure Fragen schreibt uns
eure Kommentare die postet ihr am besten
direkt in die Chats oder ihr schickt uns
eine E-Mail wir starten jetzt mit
unserer Reporterin in Istanbul Anna
Feist
hallo Anna grüß Dich hallo Jana schaut
man sich dieses Wahlergebnis an muss man
davon ausgehen dass die Türkei einen
tief gespaltenes Land ist
ja in der Tat also was wir hier am
Morgen danach aufnehmen ist diese tiefe
Spaltung es gibt zwei Lager aber was
dieses Land vereint ist die große
Ernüchterung denn beide Lager sind
enttäuscht die Erdogan Anhänger hätten
sich natürlich gewünscht dass ihr
Präsident viel Haushöhe gewinnt die
Anhänger von College sind enttäuscht
dass ihr Präsident oder ihr
Präsidentschaftskandidat jetzt nicht so
haushoch gewonnen hat wie sie ihn
gesehen hatten
du hast gerade gesagt die Menschen sind
enttäuscht wie geht es ihnen an diesem
Tag nach der Wahl ist es jetzt trotzdem
ein weiter der der Wahlkampf geht weiter
einerseits ja auf der anderen Seite ist
es auch erstmal eine kurzes durchatmen
Pause holen resetten denn es ist ja
jetzt äh es ist ja nichts entschieden es
ist ja vieles im Argen insbesondere geht
es heute darum ähm was passieren wird
mit Sinan ohan seine Stimmen sie dann
Orhan ist der dritte Präsidentschaft
kann die dort seine Stimmen 5% hat er
hinter sich versammelt die könnten nun
ausschlaggebend sein die könnten nun den
einen oder den anderen Kandidaten
helfen Präsident zu werden was kann man
denn ein bisschen jetzt sagen wir haben
welche Teile der Gesellschaft abgestimmt
also es ist ja im Vorfeld z.B dass die
erstwählerin und Wähler den
ausschlaggebenden
ja ich glaube dafür lohnt es sich mal
anzuschauen wer wo wen gewählt hat es
ist so dass Erdogan insbesondere in den
ländlichen in den marginalisierten
Regionen Stimmen geholt hat an der
Schwarzmeerküste auch auch im
Erdbebengebiet und die Opposition im
Kemal College darüber hat insbesondere
die Großstädte für sich gewinnen können
und eben auch weiter andere küstenteile
und in den Großstädten ist davon
auszugehen dass da eben auch viele
Erstwähler für College da wo du gestimmt
haben aber immerhin sollen ähm so war
die Einschätzung die wir in den letzten
Tagen gehört haben auch bis zu 35% der
Erstwähler für Erdogan gestimmt haben du
hast gerade schon diesen dritten
Kandidaten sehen ein Ohren angesprochen
der eben jetzt eine wichtige Rolle
spielen könnte weil er eben der
Königsmacher sein könnte
wie wird der sich voraussichtlich
positionieren denn er steht ja eher
rechts von Erdogan sogar aber er hat
sich aber auch ganz klar gegen ihn
gestellt
na der macht es im Moment noch spannend
er hat vor wenigen Stunden heute Nacht
hat er gesagt er wird jetzt noch keine
Aussage darüber treffen mit wem er in
aller Allianz treten könnte also zu wem
er seine Wähler Stimmen verweisen könnte
er hat nur eine Bedingung gesetzt und
die Bedingung ist jetzt ist keine Kurden
in der Allianz das ist für beide ein
Problem erdogan hat in seinem Bündnis
die Pro kurdische
islamistische hühnerpaar Glitch darogulu
ist im Wort mit der HDP der Pro
kurdischen linken Partei ob Kemal Glitch
darüber tatsächlich dieses Wort brechen
wird um dann stimmen abzugreifen das ist
allerdings hoch fraglich lass mich mal
schauen welche Fragen wir im Chat haben
ja da ist eine von Klasse die wie von
auf Youtube Anna wie lange braucht das
bis die finalen Ergebnisse verkündet
werden
das wissen wir hier auch nicht wie
rechnen damit das baldmöglichst sobald
alles ausgezählt ist und fest steht die
Ergebnisse kommen es geht im Moment noch
um ein Prozent der Stimmen deshalb da
haben wir auch keine genauen
Informationen zu vielleicht trotzdem mal
in kurzer Ausblick wie geht's jetzt
weiter wenn es so wie im Moment gibt es
am 28 Mai eine Stichwahl so wie es
aussieht wir werden jetzt die nächsten
knapp zwei Wochen verlaufen
na der Wahlkampf wird mutmaßlich wenn es
denn zu einer Stichwahl wirklich kommt
das ist ja auch noch nicht offiziell
verkündet es sieht alles danach aus aber
es ist noch nicht offiziell verkündet ja
dann wird der Wahlkampf hier mutmaßlich
weitergehen wie genau der sich gestaltet
das bleibt aber abzuwarten es gibt ja
Vorwürfe dass das Regierungslager die
Zahlen manipuliert werden haben soll da
gibt es unter anderem Vorwürfe die
kommen vom Bürgermeister von Istanbul
Imam
ja ähm diese Vorwürfe spielen an auf was
Beobachter einen Psychokrieg nennen
nämlich sollen gestern Abend bewusst
Ergebnisse angefochten wurden sein und
dann eben erst später mitgeteilt wurden
sein damit Erdogan über Stunden vorne
liegen konnte über stundenergebnisse von
über 50% seiner Wählerschaft
präsentieren konnte
wir haben das gestern so erlebt ob das
tatsächlich bewusste Taktik war
ist von auszugehen wissen wir aber auch
nicht mit allerletzte sich halt und
darüber werden wir auch gleich noch
sprechen mit dem Leiter der
wahlbeobachtungskommission mit Herrn
Schwabe vielen Dank Anna für den Moment
bevor wir weitermachen schauen wir uns
kurz einen Beitrag von der an was noch
mal die ganzen Ereignisse
zusammengefasst
Kopf an Kopf ein Zeh ist Rennen und das
könnte genauso weitergehen
natürlich sind wir enttäuscht das ist
deprimiert
ich glaube keine Partei ist mit dieser
Situation zufrieden Stunden
zuvorabend das große warm Lauf
en zu Ernüchterung noch in der Nacht
fällt der Präsident auf 49% sein
Herausforderer
pendelt sich bei 45% ein Erdogan
interpretiert das dann so
ich möchte es noch einmal betonen die
Tatsache dass die Wahlergebnisse noch
nicht endgültig fest stehen ändert
nichts an der Tatsache dass die Wahl
unserer Nation eindeutig zu unseren
Gunsten ausgefallen ist
sich davon nicht entmutigen
prognostizierte nachts zum das was immer
wahrscheinlicher wird den zweiten
Wahlgang wenn sich unser Land für eine
Stichwahl entscheidet dann zu unserem
Vergnügen wir werden diese Wahl auf
jeden Fall in der zweiten Runde gewinnen
das wird jeder sehen so sicher ist das
nicht ein dritter könnte da den
ausschlaggeben sie haben der dritte
Präsidentschaftskandidat Vorsitzender
eines nationalistischen Bündnisses mit
gut fünf Prozent der Stimmen hinter sich
er könnte nun zum Königsmacher werden
doch erstmal will der die Spannung
halten
noch wollen wir nicht sagen ob wir die
eine oder die andere Partei unterstützen
zu welchem Lager er seine Wählerschaft
Steuern wird das müssen die kommenden
Tage zeigen
und wir sprechen jetzt mit Frank Schwabe
dem Leiter der Wahl Beobachtermission
des Europarates schönen Tag
guten Tag schön dass sie Zeit für uns
haben wir haben es gerade von Anna Feist
gehört dass er ihm diese Vorwürfe im
Raum stehen dass das Regierungslager die
Zahlen manipuliert haben soll wir haben
sie das erlebt
das Problem ist dass es Raum gab gestern
für Spekulationen weil eben nicht klar
war wie eigentlich die Ergebnisse
veröffentlicht werden die oberste
Wahlkommission hat das nicht sehr
transparent gemacht und deswegen konnten
dann da auch die Medien die Erde an
sogenannt sind ob die Staatsmedien
entsprechend agieren und in der Tat hohe
Ergebnisse für Erdogan am Anfang
dokumentieren und es hat wohl und so
waren die Berichte genau diese Versuche
gegeben im Grunde genommen im Rahmen
sich das rechts bewegen in der Türkei
aber Wahlergebnisse hinauszuzögern und
möglicherweise sogar dort anzuzweifeln
wohl eben Kilo besonders hohe Ergebnisse
hat und nichtsdestotrotz heute ist das
alles ein Stück weit ruhiger erhalten
sich die hat sich die Lage etwas etwas
gesetzt und heute kann das ganz gut
beurteilen und das Ergebnis was jetzt zu
lesen es gibt schon das wieder wie
gestern die Menschen auch gewählt haben
sie sagen das bewegt sich alles im
Rahmen des Rechts am würden sie aber
auch sagen ist das guter Stil
naja insgesamt ist ja die Lage
schwierig das haben wir aber auch
mehrfach beschrieben wir haben ja die
Tage schon miteinander geredet der
Europarat beobachtet ja die Türkei ist
im sogenannten Monitoring-Verfahren und
weiß dass die Lage der Medien Freiheit
hier sehr schlecht ist dass es
politische gefangen gibt vieles andere
mehr das spiegelt sich natürlich auch im
Wahlkampf wieder es gab vollkommen
ungleiche Chancen in diesem Wahlkampf
das werden wir auch als Ergebnis unseres
Mission sicherlich so konstatieren und
sicherlich war das keine gute Situation
dass so lange Unklarheit war über die
Lage und sicherlich Erdogan die Chance
hatte auch stärker zu agieren und zu
taktieren das ist nicht gut und wir
werden das auch anmachen dass die
oberste Wahlbehörde für eine mögliche
Stichwahl besser vorbereitet sein muss
und transparenter gehen muss was würden
Sie denn insgesamt sagen wie ist der
Wahltag aus ihrer Sicht abgelaufen
würden sie insgesamt sagen sie konnten
ihren Job machen
es war sehr angespannt es gab auch
Einschränkungen was den Zugang angeht zu
Wahllokalen das hat mich auch selber
betroffen ich wurde an einer Stelle
abgehalten von dieser Wahlbeobachtung
ich hatte aber nicht den Eindruck dass
das organisiert war sondern eher
geschuldet war eben dieser hohen
Immunität und auch Unsicherheit an
diesem Wahltag sich dann manchmal
entladen hat insgesamt konnten die
Menschen aber durchaus und weniger
Ausnahmen abgesehen sehr sehr frei
wählen und man muss auch davon ausgehen
dass das was wir jetzt in den Umfragen
sehen nach vielen hin und her ruckeln
gestern in der Nacht dann auch das
widerspiegelt was an Stimmen abgegeben
wurde das ähm ist ja auch das was die
Chefin der linke geschildert hat Janine
Wissler sie sagte er auch das
Wahlbeobachter aus Deutschland teils an
ihrem Einsatz gehindert worden sein am
würden Sie sagen das ist vereinzelt
passiert oder war das doch vermehrt
man muss sich immer ein bisschen sagen
er ist eigentlich Wahlbeobachter also
wir sind hier noch offizielle Mission
internationale Missionen auch eben das
Europarats und der Organisation für
Sicherheit und Zusammenarbeit in Europa
das beschwert uns etwas über das Leben
etwas schwieriger wenn da andere auch
noch unterwegs sind eher auf privaten
Mission die haben natürlich weniger
Rechte das muss man einfach sagen wir
sind hier mit bestimmten Rechten
ausgestattet und dürfen umfassen
beobachten andere nehmen sich dann ein
Stück weit eher dieses Recht das ist
natürlich trotzdem nicht gut wenn wenn
keine Transparenz herrscht immer
in manchen Wahllokalen wo diese
Kolleginnen und Kollegen unterwegs waren
aber noch mal sehr gut wenn Sie sich
eine internationalen war Beobachtung
anschließen können dafür gibt's ja
Regeln und dann wird das auch besser
sein bei uns gab es Probleme aber in
überschaubarem Maße okay ähm wir haben
ja am Freitag schon mal gesprochen haben
sie mit und meiner Kollegin Alicia jung
gesprochen und da ging es darum dass sie
Situation ja auch nicht ganz leicht
gewesen ist denn viele der Verstorbenen
Erdbeben Opfer waren ja noch ein
Wahlregister aufgeführt wie ist diese
Situation gelöst worden war das jetzt am
Wahltag auch noch ein Problem
es gab durchaus vereinzelte
Schwierigkeiten und auch Nachfragen
werden da eigentlich wie gewählt hat
wieder Zugang zur Wahllokalen war
insgesamt aber das sieht man ja ist die
Wahlbeteiligung doch auch erstaunlich
hoch gewesen in diesen Erdbebengebieten
und es ist doch den Umständen
entsprechend das ist ja eine eine
schreckliche eine katastrophale Lage ist
es doch dort relativ geordnet auch von
Staaten gegangen ist muss man so sagen
ja
organisatorische Frage zum Schluss wenn
es denn jetzt zu einer Stichwahl kommt
am 28 Mai wonach ist ja aktuell aussieht
wenn Sie diese Wahl dann auch begleiten
ja das ist im Paket also wir hatten eine
Vorwahl Beobachtung waren schon hier wir
werden auch in 14 Tagen wieder da sein
in derselben Stärke mit 39 aktuell
Personen das Europarats dann in zwei
Wochen dann sind wir gespannt wie sie
dann ihre Arbeit machen können vielen
Dank Herr Schwabe tschüss
ja und wir haben heute Vormittag mit der
CDU-Politikerin sehr abkühler sprechen
können sie ist aktuell in der Nähe von
Istanbul ja und ich hatte sie als erstes
darauf angesprochen dass sie vor der
Wahl gesagt hatte dass die Chance
Erdogan zu schlagen eben nie so gut
gewesen wäre wie jetzt ja und dann habe
ich sie gefragt was sie denkt warum
diese Chance denn jetzt bis jetzt
offensichtlich nicht genutzt wurde
hat sicherlich ganz unterschiedliche
Gründe weil viele in dieser Situation
auch nach wie vor die Einstellung
vertreten in so einer Krise
lohnt es sich nicht oder ist es zu
gefährlich auf jemand neuen zu setzen
und es ist besser mit jemandem weiter zu
machen der eben auch jahrelange
Erfahrung mitbringt ich habe da selbst
vor drei Wochen als ich in der
Erdbebenregion beispielsweise unterwegs
war gemerkt da waren Menschen wütend
frustriert aber trotzdem der Meinung
dass der einzige ist der sie aus dieser
Krise rausholen kann und die historische
Chance lag aber oder liegt jetzt auch
für die Stichwahl eben darin dass sich
die Opposition
zusammengetan hat sechs doch sehr
unterschiedliche Parteien die einen
Kandidaten gestellt haben und ich glaube
man darf das Ergebnis jetzt allerdings
auch nicht zu klein reden selbst und die
AKP haben nicht mit einer Stichwahl
berechnet man selbst hat noch vor
wenigen Tagen gesagt eine Stichwahl das
ist etwas was für ihn so absurd ist da
hat verschwendet er keinen Gedanken und
heute wissen wir es gibt eine Stichwahl
also insofern ganz gewonnen hat also
auch nicht aber ganz gewonnen hat
auch nicht Umfragen hatten ja ein
engeres Rennen
vorhergesehen denken sie dass er das
noch für sich entscheiden kann
also die zwei Wochen die nächsten zwei
Wochen werden sehr sehr harte in der
Türkei der Wahlkampf wird härter werden
der Ton wird sicherlich auch noch mal
Bauer werden das hat man gestern auch
bei der balkonbräte von Erdogan gesehen
der die
Opposition noch mal als Jahr
Terroristen beschimpft hat als
Marionetten von von von der PKK
insofern es wird sicherlich noch mal
eine schwierige Zeit beide Lager werden
mobilisieren und jetzt kommt es auch ein
bisschen auf den Königsmacher an auf den
dritten Kandidaten
auf den dritten Kandidaten und ähm beide
werden versuchen diese 5% die der dritte
Kandidat ja ähm für sich einnehmen
konnte auf diese 5% zu ziehen und es
bleibt spannend wäre hier das Rennen
macht weil der dritte Kandidat eben
stark auch eine Anti Kurden Politik die
mir verfolgt hat und auch diese Stimmen
am Kirchdorf gehen ist tatsächlich die
große Frage das wird die große Frage
sein was sie aber auch gesagt hatten vor
der Wahl ist das ähm wenn Erdogan
gewinnt sei für sie mit dem Schlimmsten
zu rechnen was meinen Sie was ist für
sie das schlimmste
na gut er hat ja angekündigt dass es
seine letzte Periode sein wird der will
nicht noch mal antreten das ist jetzt so
sein letzter antritt das hat er gesagt
wenn man dem Glauben schenken darf dann
kann es natürlich einerseits sein dass
er jetzt milde gewähren lässt und eine
mildere Politik verfolgt das kann aber
eben auch genau das Gegenteil sein dass
er jetzt überhaupt keine Rücksicht mehr
nimmt und richtig in die Autokratie
steuert und diese Gefahr besteht und
steht weiterhin im Raum gerade nach
diesem knappen Wahlergebnis dass er es
jetzt auch gut deutsch noch mal richtig
krachen lässt in Sachen autokratische
Kurs das werden jetzt ja noch knapp zwei
Wochen bis zur Stichwahl am 28 Mai wovon
gehen sie aus wie werden Erdogan und
Rollo jetzt vorgehen um die Wählerinnen
und Wähler für sich zu gewinnen von
Seiten der AKP aus bei dieser Wahlkampf
ja schon jetzt teilweise hässlich
er war sehr hässlich und das hat man vor
allem gestern nach 17 Uhr noch mal
gemerkt ich meine das kann man sich bei
uns überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass neun
Stunden nach dem Schließen ja wohl
Wahllokale ist immer noch kein
vorläufiges Wahlergebnis gab das war ja
heute in den frühen morgenstundenstand
ja fest dass es letztendlich eine
Stichwahl geben soll das ist bei uns
wirklich unvorstellbar weil die AKP in
ganz vielen Wahllokal eben das Ergebnis
dass die GAP gewonnen hat in diesem
Wahllokal nicht anerkannt hat es gibt
Wahllokale die bis zu 11 mal nach zählen
mussten weil die AKP immer wieder
Widerspruch eingelegt hat bzw die AKP
Wahl Beobachter und da waren sieht man
es ist nicht fair gelaufen es war eine
freie Wahl weitgehend aber es war keine
Fähre Wahl weil der komplette
staatsoperator und die 90% der
Medienlandschaft hinter Allgäuern stehen
es gibt Analysen darüber wie viel
Stunden die öffentlich rechtlichen oder
die türkischen Medien überall waren
berichtet haben also angezeigt haben und
wie viel
da sind wir bei einem Trend von 30
Stunden für Kühlschrank 300 Stunden für
Erdogan also es ist keine faire war
gewesen und es ist leider zu vermuten
dass es in den nächsten zwei Wochen noch
mal unfair war zu gehen wird
die Linie verfolgt eine Umarmung der
Politik ein umarmenden Wahlkampf zu
machen wo er viel auf Demokratie gesetzt
hat Demokratie demokratische Werte hoch
gehalten hat und auch immer wieder die
Ankündigung gemacht hat dass es mit ihm
zurück in die Demokratie gehen wird und
ich glaube was die AKP und alban
betrifft wird der Ton einfach noch mal
sauer werden die Vorwürfe dass eine
Marionette der Terroristen Terroristen
sei wie noch mal gestern während seiner
Balkon Rede das wird jetzt glaube ich
noch mal stärker gefahren
werden schlagen wir vielleicht noch mal
den Bogen ähm nach Deutschland
entspricht dieses Wahlergebnis im großen
und ganzen auch dem der türkischen
Community in Deutschland also ist man da
ähnlich gespalten in der Frage wer
künftig das Land regieren soll
ja die Spaltung ist riesig tatsächlich
ist es zu vergleichen mit den USA das
sprechen wir ja auch immer eine Spaltung
und die geht hier wirklich in der Türkei
mitten durch die Gesellschaft in
Deutschland auch ich kenne auch in
Deutschland Freunde die nicht mehr
miteinander reden weil der eine
ebenfalls findet und der andere nicht
also dieser Streit wird tatsächlich auch
bei uns in Deutschland ausgetragen
wobei man sagen muss dass die letzten
Wahlen bei den Wahlberechtigten Türken
die dann auch an der Wahl teilgenommen
haben das ist ungefähr von 500000 450
bis 500.000 stark eine Unterstützung ist
für Einhorn gab es ist davon auszugehen
dass das diesmal ähnlich sein wird vor
allem wenn wir uns anschauen woher die
meisten Türkei ständigen in Deutschland
kommen das sind schon vor allem Regionen
in Anatolien und da sehen wir auch jetzt
wenn wir auf die Wahlkarte von gestern
Abend schauen dass er dort auch da
wieder gewonnen hat mit Verlusten aber
trotzdem gewonnen hat was bedeutet
Szenario 1 Erdogan regiert weiter für
die Beziehung zu Deutschland und was
bedeutet Szenario 2volo wird neuer
Präsident für die Beziehung
für uns in Deutschland und Europa
bedeutet das mit algoran ein weiter so
und die Beziehungen in den letzten
Jahren sind schlechter geworden oder die
Beziehung ist schlechter geworden und
größere hat zumindest im Wahlkampf immer
wiederholt immer wieder wiederholt dass
er einen pro-europäischen pro westlichen
Kurs wieder verfolgen möchte dass er
zurück zu Demokratie möchte dass er die
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Türkei
mit mit Europa wieder aufnehmen möchte
und auch dass es mit ihm kann weh tut
zur Natur Mitgliedschaft Schweden geben
wird mit anderen ist er ein weiter so zu
denken also ich glaube für uns das wäre
tatsächlich der bessere angenehmere
Partnerschaft
vielen Dank für das Gespräch machen sie
es gut tschüss danke dir auch alles Gute
ja die größte türkische Community
außerhalb ihrer Heimat lebt in
Deutschland und 1,5 Millionen Menschen
sollten hierzulande ihre Stimme für die
Parlaments und Präsidentschaftswahl in
der Türkei abgeben unser Reporter
Dominik Müller Russell steht in der
kolbstraße in Köln einer Straße in der
sehr sehr viel türkisches Leben in
Deutschland stattfindet hallo Dominik
ja hallo
Dominik Serap Güler hat das gerade
angesprochen die türkische Community in
Deutschland ist auch gespalten wie die
Menschen in der Türkei wie tief ist
dieser Graben
ja dieser Graben der scheint wirklich
tief zu sein und das sieht man daran
dass die Wahlbeteiligung der
Auslandstürken so hoch war wie noch nie
in der Vergangenheit 53 Prozent der
Türken die im Ausland leben haben bei
dieser Wahl ihre Stimme abgegeben so
viele wie noch nie bei einer Wahl zuvor
wenn man sich jetzt mal Deutschland
anschaut da gibt's vorläufige Zahlen wir
haben die Menschen gewählt in
Deutschland zwei Drittel der Deutschen
die hier gewählt haben die haben
tatsächlich für Erdogan gestimmt das
sind sogar noch ein paar Stimmen mehr
als bei der letzten Wahl nur ein knappes
Drittel hat für den Herausforderer seine
Stimme abgegeben ja woran liegt das wir
haben in den letzten Wochen viel mit
Menschen hier gesprochen auch hier auf
der Kreuzstraße hinter mir und viele
Menschen hier sagen ja wir sind für
Erdogan einfach deshalb weil Erdogan die
Türkei in den letzten Jahren so
vorangebracht hat Erdogan hat Autobahnen
gebaut er hat die Flughäfen gebaut er
hat Krankenhäuser gebaut er die ganze
Infrastruktur vorangebracht und das ist
den Menschen hier wichtig
sagen wir reisen regelmäßig in die
Türkei und wir können einfach wir können
es richtig sehen wie Erdogan die Türkei
von dem armenland zu einer modernen Land
gemacht hat in den letzten Jahren
erdogan hat das auch geschickt gemacht
erdogan hat ja auch die Menschen
hierzulande ganz gezielt angesprochen
die Deutsch Türken und gesagt wenn ihr
euch hier in Deutschland nicht so recht
zu Hause fühlt denkt immer dran ihr seid
Türken ihr gehört bei uns dazu ja und
das hat den Menschen eben auch
Selbstbewusstsein gegeben und ich glaube
mit entscheidend ist einfach auch dass
viele Deutsch Türken aus dem gleichen ja
konservativ islamischen Milieu kommen
aus dem eben auch Erdogan kommt deswegen
ist die Verbundenheit so groß auf der
anderen Seite gibt es natürlich auch
viele Menschen die eben für bestimmte
haben ja Menschen die sich Sorgen machen
um den Zustand der Türkei Sorgen machen
um die Demokratie in der Türkei aber das
ist eben nur ein knappes Drittel der
Menschen die hier ihre Stimmen abgegeben
haben die sind jetzt enttäuscht wenn es
jetzt zur Stichwahl kommt wird ja auch
wieder in Deutschland
abgestimmt wie wird das ablaufen wenn
die stimmen dann auch wieder vor dem
eigentlichen Stichwahl Termin abgegeben
ja das wird tatsächlich so sein das
müssen die Generalkonsulate jetzt
organisieren vom 20 bis zum 24 mai soll
man seine Stimme abgeben können für die
Stichwahl in Deutschland also auch
wieder mehrere Tage lang und ja das gibt
es das gilt jetzt zu organisieren da
wird es vermutlich jetzt auch noch
Wahlkampf geben in den Tagen davor die
vor allem die AKP hat ja in den letzten
Wochen hier und Monaten hier in
Deutschland auch viel Wahlkampf
Wahlkampf betrieben so ein bisschen
unterhalb der Deutschen
wahrnehmungsstelle so möchte ich mal
nennen ja und da wird's wie gesagt jetzt
auch wieder viel Wahlkampf geben ist zu
vermuten und den knapp zwei Wochen
werden wir dann mehr Wissen vielen Dank
Dominik nach Köln tschüss
tschüss ja und wir gehen jetzt noch mal
zurück in die Türkei und sprechen mit
dem Leiter der heinrich-ball-stiftung
Istanbul mit Christian Brakel
hallo
hat vorhin gesagt dass sie vermutet dass
sie Menschen in der Türkei vielleicht
eher das gewählt haben was sie kennen
also Erdogan und in unsicheren Zeiten
nicht bereit waren für einen neuen
Präsidenten würden sie das so
unterschreiben es ist nicht gelungen Mut
für Veränderung zu machen
also man muss ja auch sagen
dieser
Präsidentschaftskandidat diese
oppositionsfront hat etwas geschafft was
im letzten 20 Jahren nicht möglich war
nämlich wirklich relativ nah an Erdogan
heranzukommen das ist am Ende nicht
gereicht hat dafür gibt es glaube ich
verschiedene Gründe einer ist der glaube
ich den Vorbilder angesprochen hat ein
anderer haben ist aber sicherlich auch
dass in solchen autokratischen Regime
immer gemacht habe mehr profitiert das
ist ja auch kein gleiches Spielfeld auf
dem die beiden Kandidaten angetreten
sind was etwa die Zeit Kontrolle in den
Medien angeht aber auch solche Dinge
etwas wie
[Musik]
zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit
Wahlgeschenke zu machen irgendwie von
staatlichen Geldern da war er dann
natürlich klaren Vorteil und zuletzt
auch das muss man auch sehen die
Verfassungsänderung die ist 2017 gegeben
hat wie zielte ja genau darauf ab
nämlich die Macht des konservativ
religiösen Blocks zu zementieren die
Menschen eben vor die Wahl zu stellen
dass sie in lang identitärer Linien
wählen müssen die für viele sehr
schwierig zu überschreiten wird es gibt
einen Kommentar auf Youtube Erdogan muss
leider nichts manipulieren ja was oder
immer Mono hätten garantiert gewonnen
aber aus irgendeinem Grund auch immer
hat man den unsympathischsten Kandidaten
aufgestellt das spielt eben auf auf das
fehlende Karies mal das Kind Downloader
auch immer vorgeworfen wurde hat das
auch so ein Punkt gehabt
ob es einen großen Unterschied gegeben
hätte bei anderen Kandidaten können wir
nicht sagen natürlich kilage war ein
Kompromisskandidat aber er war
wahrscheinlich auch der einzig
vernünftige Kandidat den die Opposition
aufstellen konnte ja was hätte nicht die
Unterstützung der Kurden bekommen also
der HDP bzw
yesterday ähm und damit wären dann auch
noch mal 8 bis 9 % weggefallen und
imamolu ich meine gegen den läuft halt
jetzt seit einiger Zeit eine
Ermittlungsverfahren bzw schwebt sogar
eine Urteil über ihm die
Wahrscheinlichkeit wäre sehr sehr hoch
gewesen dass er mitten im Wahlkampf
einfach verurteilt worden wäre in
zweiter Instanz und dann komplett aus
dem Regen gewesen wäre also von daher
Philipp ja ein Kompromisskandidat aber
wahrscheinlich der einzig Möglichkeit
aber hier kommt noch mal die Frage von
Bulle train auf Youtube ähm würde erolo
überhaupt regieren können wenn er denn
keine Mehrheit im Parlament hat denn
gestern hat er auch eine Parlamentswahl
stattgefunden und da hat er die dakp von
Erdogan weiter die Mehrheit
ja das ist eine sehr sehr berechtigte
Frage ich glaube dieses
parlamentsergebnis die weiß sehr stark
darauf hin wohin die zweite Runde der
Präsidentschaftswahlen gehen wird die
Person hat gestern schon in seiner Rede
gesagt
wenn jetzt nicht die Präsidentschaft an
ihn gehen sollte dann wäre die Regierung
ja quasi handlungsunfähig und das müsste
sich die WählerInnen Wähler ja ganz
genau überlegen und ich denke das wird
einer der wichtigsten Punkte sein auf
den in dieser Wahlkampf in den nächsten
zwei Wochen laufen wird es ist stimmt
nicht ganz dass der Präsident nichts
machen könnte ohne die Parlaments
Mehrheit dafür sorgt ja diese
Verfassungsänderung von 2017 die den
Präsidenten sehr viele Vollmachten gibt
aber dass die Lämmer da wäre natürlich
dass viele davon also dass der regieren
etwa per Präsident sehr sehr
undemokratisch ist und genau das
Gegenteil von dem was wir Opposition
eigentlich versprochen
letzte Frage an Sie vor der Wahl wurde
oft gesagt es geht um eine
Schicksalswahl und das klingt natürlich
sehr pathetisch aber das ist ja ein
Stück weit tatsächlich allein wenn man
an die tausenden Menschen denkt die
aktuell in aus politischen Gründen in
Gefängnissen sitzen für die hier ist es
wirklich eine Schicksalswahl weil es
über ihr weiteres Schicksal entscheidet
was denken Sie wer wird neuer oder alter
Präsident der Türkei und in welche
Richtung wird sich das Land dann
verändern
ich glaube das ist sehr gut dass sie das
noch mal erwähnt haben also es gibt
natürlich einfach Fälle viele Leute wie
Osman Kavala mit Jella Jacke die in
diesem gelsen Verfahren vor allen Dingen
verurteilt worden sind die grundlos im
Gefängnis sitzen und eigentlich auch
einer Meinung des europäischen Gerichts
für Menschenrechte schon lange hätten
lassen werden sollen weil es nicht
Substanzielles gibt was man ihm
irgendwie nachgewiesen hat und für die
ist natürlich dieses Ergebnis besonders
niederschmettern und ja also meine
Vermutung ist tatsächlich dass sich auch
einen zweiten Wahlgang Erdogan
durchsetzen wird denn ihm fehlen nur
wenige Stunden bis zur Mehrheit er
braucht auch jetzt in in diesem zweiten
Wahlgang braucht der noch nicht mal über
50% sondern er muss nur mehr Stimmen
bekommen das hat er ja jetzt schon fünf
Prozent Ursprung und wo sollten diese
fünf Prozent oder ja sogar ein bisschen
mehr für die Opposition herkommen sie
hatten gerade in Beitrag schon
angesprochen
dieser rechtsradikale
der Macht zu Bedingungen das dass wir
Opposition sich von der Kunden verteilt
distanziert
aber ungefähr fast 9% der Stimmen das
bedeutet da würde man ein sehr
schlechtes Geschäft eingehen also die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass am Ende uns doch
aber anhalten bleibt sind sehr groß und
spätestens am 28 Mai sind wir dann
schlauer aber Brackel ich danke Ihnen
für das Gespräch viele Grüße nach
Istanbul
ja und ich danke euch ganz herzlich für
eure Fragen und eure Kommentare wir
machen für heute Schluss und sehen uns
hoffentlich bald wieder ZDF heute live
bis dann tschüss